und vielleicht an frank die frage wie
schwer ist es denn dazu so jemand zu
einem v mann der ein doppelleben führt
vertrauen aufzubauen
ja man muss dazu sagen wir haben uns ja
schon kennengelernt vor vielen jahren
und zwar zusammen mit meiner tätigkeit
als das wort aber meine recherchen eben
damals zusammen
aland rockern diesen satt oder auch wenn
die damals ich hier in duisburg
breitmachten und eben den hells angels
konkurrenz machen wollen und in dem
zusammenhang wir uns kennengelernt und
deswegen konnten wir uns und da kann er
ja in der gleich auch noch was zu sagen
er ist ja dann auch nach seiner
tätigkeit selber sechs jahre ins
gefängnis gegangen und nach seiner
haftentlassung haben wir uns wieder
getroffen und er hat mir dann erzählt
dass dahinter steckt ich wusste dass
damals ja auch überhaupt nicht dass er
dieses doppelleben leben führt und habe
die sache natürlich nach recherchiert
was erzählt haben dann hat sich
herausgestellt dass stimmt eben alles so
und der hat eben in hamburg für slk
jahre arbeitet ihr noch ein westfalen
eben auch als v-mann und das
interessanteste war sogar dass seine
harley der hier gefahren ist sogar aus
steuergeldern bezahlt wurde nämlich vom
land weil er die ja auch zumindest zähne
sich sozusagen zu etablieren und das
waren natürlich spannende einblicke und
details die man so sonst ja auch nicht
mitbekommen man kennt die fälle
man kennt die ganzen situation die er
dann beschreibt aber man ist plötzlich
den anderen blickwinkeln mit
und das war eigentlich das wirklich
spannende und auch ungewöhnliche an
diesen einblicken die welt bekommen habe
herstellen zwischen ihnen beiden ein
vertrauensverhältnis
ja ich würde schon sagen ein gewisses
vertrauen notwendig sein das kann man ja
das auch nicht so zusammen machen
er hat ja auch sich uns anvertraut er
geht ja auch damit ein hohes risiko
erste frage die ich mir natürlich
gestellt warum macht er das überhaupt da
geht es nicht um geld oder was er wollte
einfach mehr oder weniger mit seinem
alten eben auch freuen und auch einmal
klarmachen
ich war eben nicht nur den wert bei
sondern ich habe eben auch so gesagt was
gute gekämpft ich habe ein doppelleben
geführt und das kann er vielleicht
selber auch noch mal am besten erklären
er wollte ja auch eine art schlussstrich
ziehen und einmal für alle mal sagen mit
dem thema ist für mich vor weichen mit
dem milieu nichts mehr zu tun haben